salve quello che vedete le mie spalle è
una ricostruzione del pianeta terra di
notte
c'è un satellite che prende fette di
territorio alla fotografa e se voi foste
dei marziani che atterrano sul nostro
pianeta
potreste scegliere di atterrare in una
zona ampia mente illuminata come questa
o questa o questa che è un simbolo di
pianeta avanzato dove si vive a lungo
oppure afferrare da qualche parte dove
il futuro non c'è perché si vive poco si
vive male
a proposito di chi dice che il futuro ce
lo costruiamo no ci sono delle cose che
non si spengono e purtroppo quelle che
dobbiamo affrontare questa mappa
corrisponde a questa che l'aspettativa
di vita in verde si campa più di 75 anni
in giallo si campa
fra i 50 e 60 in rosso si campo poco e
quindi c'è una corrispondenza 1 1 fra la
possibilità di avere energia
illuminazione istruzione ospedali
welfare scuole è l'aspettativa di vita
su questo pianeta
allora chi fa chi ha il compito di fare
tecnologia e di mettere a disposizione
quelle macchine con le stesse macchine
che fanno cose inutili come i social
nella maggior parte dei casi e che
consumano quantità di energia spaventose
perché noi ci preoccupiamo tutti quanti
del fatto di essere addicted di
diventare dipendenti da una droga
pressoché inutile e non ci preoccupiamo
del danno che invece fanno ad altri
livelli
chi fa tecnologia deve capire che il
pianeta se già spezzato in due abbia una
grande bottiglia in un angolo c'è acqua
100 gr di tutto il resto è acqua 20
gradi
ditemi se vi sembra sociologicamente
nonché termodinamicamente sopportabile
come approccio questa
è la descrizione del pianeta terrà oggi
e dobbiamo pensare per il futuro che
esiste due tipi di tecnologia uno per la
società come la nostra ricche e che
hanno la fortuna di invecchiare hanno la
fortuna di morire di cancro di morire di
attacchi di cuore di queste malattie
degli esseri che vivono lungo e in
queste società bisogna creare un nuovo
welfare
il welfare che viene generato dal
vecchio welfare abbiamo avuto medicinale
abbiamo avuto ospedali scuole adesso
campiamo più a lungo dobbiamo garantirci
una terza età fra 30 anni avremo un 35
per cento della popolazione che oltre 65
anni a questi bisognerà garantire un
invecchiamento sano non ha senso vivere
per vivere male quindi riabilitazione
sostenibilità delle avanzate screening
predittivo medicine personalizzate in
cui il singolo evento sulla singola
cellula viene sostanzialmente corretto e
poi avremo una larga fetta della
popolazione che invece deve crescere ha
bisogno del basic è il fercolo che
abbiamo già noi medicinale basso costo
diagnostiche portatili dove non ci sono
gli ospedali informatizzazione
trasferimento di tecnologie allungamento
della vita grazie all'ingente
all'alimentazione alla cultura e non è
così semplice perché la popolazione
cresce ulteriormente saremo fra una
ventina d'anni i 9 miliardi
in realtà c'è un problema di
sostenibilità
l'essere umano è un parassita nel senso
biologico del termine non costruiamo
nulla produciamo consumiamo e basta e il
sistema chiuso pianeta a un certo una
certa quantità di risorse da darci che
poi sono finite questo richiede un
approccio misto scienza dei materiali
nano tecnologia robotica computazione
informatica nel senso molto ampio e
scienze della vita e questo è il nostro
dovere
date un'occhiata a queste tabelle sono
ovunque su internet non vi voglio
annoiare troppo siamo altro pizan do il
15 per cento della superficie terrestre
cento anni fa era irrilevante questa
percentuali ta perdiamo
oggi si parla di biodiversità non
l'estinzione delle specie sono maggiori
di cento all'anno in questo in termini
milioni all'anno
abbiamo limiti proposte 10 al livello
pre industriale era minore di uno
qualunque cosa guardate co2 buchi della
zona prendete un parametro qualsiasi
sceglietelo voi vedrete che c'è un
problema serio di costruzione di questo
futuro allora primo problema dell'acqua
oggi abbiamo consumi da 350 litri al
giorno per una famiglia in america e 165
in europa in africa eventi il fabbisogno
minimo dal punto della sopravvivenza 5
litri al giorno
il fabbisogno civile 50 litri al giorno
qui vedete delle spugne modificata con
delle tecnologie nano su cui non vi a
noi non è un talk scientifico e voglio
solo a farvi mettervi alcune lucine
rosse in testa alcuni warning
queste sono spugne che sono state
modificate inserendo delle molecole
artificiali che come vedete sono in
grado di tirar via l'olio dall'acqua
questa e olio che galleggiava sull'acqua
la spugna non assorbe l'arco assorbe
l'olio qual è il concetto è quello di
dire io posso filtrare una falda che
negli ultimi vent'anni si è abbassata di
20 metri
stiamo perdendo le poche riserve di
acqua dolce si stanno esaurendo da una
rapidità impressionante e non riusciamo
a purificare gli strati profondi
perché questo la gente non ha capito che
l'energia costa acqua oggi produrre un
megawatt ora a mezzo di sorgenti
idroelettriche costa 80 mila litri di
acqua produrre la stessa quantità di
potenza oraria concentrare carbone
200mila litri per il raffreddamento con
la fissione 150.000 litri key energy ac
all'acqua
chi mangia più energia vuole più acqua
usando tanta acqua c'è un problema di
sopravvivenza perché ci sono dei limiti
fisici alla quantità di acqua che
abbiamo la tecnologia deve andare in
questa direzione
torna al discorso di garantire a noi un
esistenza più lunga che essendo già
fortunati perché ce l'abbiamo lunga date
le zone in cui viviamo costruire sistemi
intelligenti la natura creato oggetti
come gli anticorpi dei dei sistemi che
avessero turano che si riconoscono
biologicamente per cui in generale siamo
in grado di aggredire
oggi no e di farlo fuori ecco bisogna
creare degli anticorpi artificiali
questo come sono delle tecnologie che
stanno sviluppando molto bene oggi si
fanno delle piccole navicelle da 20 30
miliardesimi di metro sono tipicamente
200 atomi di diametro sono dei magneti
molto piccoli ossidi di ferro vengono
coperti con delle spugne di polimero
sono delle spugnette delle proprie di
100 milioni di m
intorno a queste spugnette ci sono delle
molecole che sono in grado di molecole
in grado di riconoscere la specifica
malattia che noi vogliamo attaccare e la
spugnetta è in grado di assorbire
chemioterapico un antinfiammatorio
questo oggetto tutto quanto e 150
nanometri il sistema immunitario non lo
vede è in grado di passare la gran parte
delle barriere delle cellule trova la
cellula malata perché i riconoscitori
quelli azzurri il polimero si dice il
respons
cioè in grado di riconoscere variazioni
di phd temperatura e quindi in grado di
rilasciare il medicinale dove serve e
mentre fa questo mestiere
siccome queste un magnete da anche un
contrasto in risonanza magnetica e
siccome è un materiale super para
magnetico se c'è una radiofrequenza
l'esterno riscalda fa ipertermia capite
una pallina un proiettile
intelligentissimo di 150 miliardesimi di
metro che fa diagnostica e terapia
insieme questa è roba che si deve
vendere come presidio farmaceutico un
giorno e che deve eliminare tutto quello
che è il la conseguenza macroscopica di
una nella chemioterapia massiva come la
facciamo oggi ma ribadisco è un lusso
la scoperta che mi ha fatto vedere prima
la tecnologia di prima riguardava i
poveracci che non l'acqua questa
riguarda quelli ricchi che avevano a
lungo come noi
ed è qui un po la divaricazione delle
tecnologie che per fortuna hanno tutte
una stessa matrice che lo studio degli
atomi delle molecole dal basso mettendo
insieme un altro esempio che vi do
giusto per per dirvi dove si può
arrivare oggi ci sono ormai dei chip di
plastica erano molto piccola costa poche
decine di centesimi di euro in cui è
possibile mobilizzare un singolo
filamento di dna queste questo è proprio
un filamento singolo una
una roba di 2 300 nanometri questi
costano 20 micron di lunghezza e 200
anche a me non hanno metri di spessore
che viene immobilizzata dove serve e che
può essere studiata selettivamente una
singola molecola per fare quello che noi
chiamiamo la diagnosi molto precoce per
andare a vedere se ci sono dei
cambiamenti con delle tecniche su cui
non vi annoio in questo momento allora
doveva questo tipo di tecnologia
l'idea che domani un domani non troppo
lontano si possono portare delle delle
piastrine di plastica dal costo molto
basso su cui si sputa su cui si fa un
cosiddetto book als craxi prendo un po
di sangue dalle gengive un qualsiasi
fluido di tipo biologico e queste
contengono una serie di reagenti
colorimetrici che ci dicono sia una
certa mutazione avvenuta bisogna
conoscere molte cose ovviamente sapere
che malattia si cerca eccetera ma ci
dice in maniera colori m k on off
ovviamente se offrono c'è problema se
non si deve cercare un ospedale vicino
dove non ci sono gli ospedali
altro problema insostenibile
produciamo 290 milioni di tonnellate di
plastica ogni anno la plastica
biodegrada 1000 1200 anni ed è un
composto del petrolio come sapete la
cosa paradossale che tutto è fatto di
fibre in natura o tal'altro meno dalla
riflessione interessante quando sentivo
il bellissimo intervento sull'evoluzione
che facevi prima quel fantastico albero
trilobato per noi fisici è una cosa
ancora più intrigante perché il 90 per
cento di quei rami sono fatti da sei
atomi sono sempre gli stessi
la natura fa mette a disposizione un
centinaio di atomi però poi tutta quella
roba aveva fatto vedere di evoluzione
bellissima dal set dall unicellulare a
tutte le specie umane e animali eccetera
sono 56 atomi 85 90 per cento della
massa e idrogeno ossigeno carbonio
calcio azoto dal front quindi
immaginatevi poi se la volete scomporre
l'evoluzione una cosa fa è una cosa
facile se i mattoncini lego cambiate
l'architettura e fatte dall organismo
unicellulare all'elefante passando per
l'uomo
e sono tutte fibre torno al mio discorso
perché poi in realtà noi siamo tutte
fibre fibre muscolari oggetti che si
contraggono alla fine è tutta roba lunga
che in qualche modo si interconnette
persino il cervello se non avesse certe
cose prolungate che creano sinapsi gli
assoli eccetera non funzionerebbe come
funziona allora se la fibra e il metodo
e la meccanica della vita è basata sulle
fibre e si fa tutto sempre con idrogeno
ossigeno carbone eccetera ma perché la
plastica noi la facciamo col petrolio
sprechiamo nella sola europa 24 milioni
24 milioni di tonnellate di vegetali di
scarto perché noi facciamo prezzemolo
facciamo riso facciamo cacao caffè e
tutto lo scarto viene buttato questo è
per il 90 per cento cellulosa e lignina
che sono delle fibre sono degli zuccheri
esistono adesso delle tecnologie per
recuperare questa cellulosa qui vedete
vado direttamente risultato
questa e plastica cento per cento
prezzemolo questa biodegrada in pochi
mesi la possiamo fare
grazie
sì si può fare si può fare col
prezzemolo si può fare con il visto non
si può fare con il sedano con il
finocchio con il caffè con il cacao
abbiamo tutti i vegetali possibile
entrati laboratorio sentite sembra di
stare in un fruttivendolo
la cosa interessante che di solito si
paga per smaltire questi materiali
queste diventano fonte di revenue se c'è
un problema di business model visto che
ci sono tanti economisti portiamo tutti
gli scarti in un posto con i tir oppure
ognuno si fa la sua plastica ma è troppo
poca perché la plastica e massiva lo
stiamo studiando però funziona
altro problema invecchiamo abbiamo
problemi di terapie parallele tanti
malati tanta gente che ha bisogno di
riabilitazione dopo l'incidente o per
vecchiaia o semplicemente perché ha
avuto degli ictus ed è cruciale
riprendere una persona che ha avuto un
ictus nei primi minuti anche se anche se
non è cosciente e non possiamo avere un
fisioterapista per malato soprattutto
perché malati crescono allora qui vedete
questo è quello che noi facciamo come
forse come attività principale bio
ispirarsi queste sono questione è un
mezzo essere umano dotato di un sistema
vestibolare avanzatissimo con tutto
l'apparato biomeccanico scheletro
muscolare identico al nostro ovviamente
finto artificiale vedete cosa fanno
muove i fianchi fa tutto quello che
facciamo noi è in grado di alzare piedi
quando non lo spinge e vive e consumano
190 watt come le gambe di un essere
umano
l'essere umano una macchina da un
kilowatt circa da 1000 watt come un
frigorifero una lavatrice quindi pone
anche un problema energetico
interessante questo ormai è il
generatore di una serie di tecnologie
che può essere con riabilitare i polsi
le spalle le gambe perché è una
tecnologia che si fa tutto il corpo ma
come voi sapete c'è mens sana in corpore
sano e quindi se noi lavoriamo su un
corpo che dovrà aiutarci un giorno dove
le protesi impiantate aiutare i malati
gli anziani eccetera
ci sarebbe anche questo corpo pensi
sappia prendere piccola decisione e ci
assista questo è il nostro bambino che
ha una intelligenza diciamo da bimbo di
un anno e mezzo non nulla di più che si
possa fare previsioni anche perché qui
vedete ha imparato a scrivere ha fatto
training per molti mesi ho imparato
l'alfabeto adesso in grado di scrivere
il suo nome che si scrive il cubo aicap
cucciolo di robot
ci sono diverse varianti è un nuovo
ecosistema bipedi quadrupedi centauri
fauni resa nota proprio non possiamo
montare pezzi è un'evoluzione molto
bisogno ispirata ma potrebbe diventare
beyond evolution tutto questo no perché
potremmo anche decidere che ci servono 6
gambe sette braccia e un'ala o fare un
oggetto che ha quattro gambe ma che
idrodinamico non è non è quello il
problema
e chiaro che queste macchine pensano
devono essere in grado di pensare sono
compagni del cittadino perché tutti
vogliamo un telefonino quando potremmo
avere fra dicendo una cosa più
sofisticata che un aiutante che stira
lava lavora negli ambienti pericolosi
cure malati li porta in bagno quando non
possono deambulare o fanno grandi grandi
processi produttivi in ambienti rumorosi
pericolosi riflettete questo è
fondamentalmente l'unico aiuto che noi
possiamo dare agli esseri umani in un
mondo che sta diventando stretto e tra
l'altro questo crea componenti parti che
sono utili per aiutare quelli che hanno
perso mobilità c'è tutto un mondo
assistenza agli anziani monitoraggio
disaster recovery aiuto in casa dal
divertimento educazione se pensate cosa
ha fatto il telefonino pensate cosa può
fare questo ma per fare le cose che vi
dico
bisogna andare al core alla capacità di
fare i conti
io non mi però come francamente del
fatto che stiamo estraniandoci con
facebook con i social troppo
informazioni ma chi se ne frega c'è il
pulsante spegnete non avete problemi
qual è il problema io ve lo dico io
quelle problema che le droghe quelle
inutili danno dipendenza ed è difficile
spegnere il pulsante ma quello è un
problema di debolezza dell'essere umano
non è un problema della tecnologia
il problema è un altro e che se il
silicio fosse stata la cosa giusta e del
silicio quello dei computer che ci
permette di avere internet tutto il
resto non ci saremmo voluti verso silice
metallo invece noi siamo acqua al
carbonio
questo è il vero messaggio
dell'evoluzione la sorgente più
adattativa di pensiero di calcolo ea più
basso consumo
noi metabolici allora per domani visto
che il futuro io insisto un po ce lo
dobbiamo accettare dobbiamo avere delle
contingenze strategies quindi
intelligenza in cloud e le
infrastrutture perché abbiamo l'uno per
cento di rete in italia facciamo ridere
dovremo crescere e questo è un aspetto
sicuramente di politica della
comunicazione della tecnologia ma per
dopodomani
cominciamo a chiederci silicio verso
neuroni 40 milioni di transistor una cpu
di computer che si parlano 1 con i dieci
primi vicini 10 alla 14 transistor nel
mio cervello in una struttura
tridimensionale non piatta dove ogni
neurone ne vede 20.000 alta
interconnessione plasticità neurale
sinapsi plasticity poi vabbè roba un
pochino meno meno divulgativa come
parlano i computer con gli elettroni
corrente elettrica come parla il
cervello con gli ioni che sono atomi
duemila volte più pesanti degli
elettroni che galleggiano in acqua
quando vengono i crampi e perché non
abbiamo più sali nuovi piloni e si
contrae il muscolo è sempre lo stesso
meccanismo che ci dà il segnale batterie
verso metabolismo c'è bisogno della
batteria per il computer e facciamolo
questo conto io 85 kg corro in
bicicletta quando faccio le mie misure
biometriche un kilowatt e lo tiro fuori
con 450 kcal pezzo di cioccolata tutto
il giorno parlo e faccio 10 alla 18
operazioni al secondo
un miliardo di miliardi di operazioni al
secondo il mio computer con le mie
quattro 150 kcal st acceso due minuti e
fa 2 milioni di operazioni al secondo
e molto veloce ma sono incomparabilmente
meglio io di lui no siamo tutti noi
incomparabilmente meglio allora la
volete una internet seria
partiamo da un presupposto l'essere
umano è l'internet fidanzata che ci sia
10 alla 18 per azione al secondo con 450
kcal nessuno compete con noi
l'internet normale fa petabyte al giorno
15 petabyte e al giorno come traffico
dati è niente rispetto a quello che
facevano in un secondo ed elettronica
allora dobbiamo evolvere la tecnologia
in questa direzione
una bio in spite technology e infine
l'energia perché questa cosa va
alimentata e io onestamente batterie non
ne vogliono nessuna parte quindi vorrei
che ci fosse un meccanismo di
alimentazione after tomorrow che è un
meccanismo diciamo più biomimetico
l'ideale sarebbe prendere l'immondizia
mettere nella cella combustibile e
questa genera con cicli noti degli
zuccheri o dell'idrogeno e questi
alimentano l'elettrodomestico umano
il robot umano e quindi il 20 per cento
del consumo energetico del pianeta che
house keeping diciamo l'elettronica di
casa potrebbe essere alimentato dall
immondizia oppure e concludo se mi fate
partire questo filmato per piacere che
non posso d'acqua vedete questo ragazzo
sta soffiando su un pezzettino di
plastica che come nottata è molto molto
piccolo e plastica questa
e mentre sofia vedete chiaramente che
qui si genera questo misuratore di
tensione si genera un segnale questo
oggetto può generare tipicamente un
volta e mezzo con la velocità di un
soffio 12 metri al secondo
immaginate di andare in bicicletta di
averlo sulle macchine sui treni e
plastica risente della turbolenza sotto
la chiglia delle navi su qualunque cosa
si muova e questo è in grado di produrre
energia sapete quanta energia
ognuno di noi dissipa camminando
semplicemente contro la gravità quello
che sto facendo io 60 watt è persa le
sospensioni delle vostre automobili
vibrando generano centinaia di latte
recuperiamo le energie persa ci
carichiamo il cellulare si può fare
questo si può usare come vi dicevo la
produzione di matica si possono stare i
batteri l'immondizia si può far tanta
roba
va gestita localmente con delle macchine
piccole che sono come il nostro fegato
un chilo e mezzo di centrale energetica
che alimenta un oggetto di 85 kg e
cominciamo a pensare in modo nuovo
ecco allora se è vero che il futuro lo
facciamo noi secondo me si fa così tutto
il resto francamente mi sembra
il passaggio intermedio in cui quasi
quasi noi la tecnologia la subiamo
invece internet e il nuovo welfare
la tecnologia è quello che deve
garantire l'esistenza della specie
allora concludo qual è il futuro secondo
noi technology secondo noi biechi ardue
risti nel g8
facciamo e che g20 si campa sino a 80
anni voglio accampare di più e vi ho
detto cosa pensiamo di fare nel 1750
l'aspettativa di vita era 27 anni
pensate come cresciuta in altri posti
invece ferma dobbiamo ridurre le
differenze rendere il pianeta
sostenibile del nostro meglio e una
questione di cultura di logica e di
tecnologia poi ricordatevi che a un
certo punto non basterà
e come nel 1492 qualcuno ha preso la
nave io poi vivo a genova quindi ed è
andato a trovare posti nuovi
qualcuno dovrà prendere la nave e andare
a cercare altri posti quindi la ricerca
quella con le ospiti deriva in quella
sulle cose che forse non avranno mai
bisogna continuare a farla perché se c'è
speranza che qualcuno voglia andarsene
gliela dobbiamo dare bisogna della
speranza a chi rimane e speranza a chi
vuole andar via
e questo secondo me il dovere della
tecnologia grazie